danny if we're still single in five
years
and we haven't found anybody can we make
a pact
that we will kill each other yeah
absolutely
oh
you okay yeah
yeah i'm good
oh my god what did you do to your hair i
cut it
oh i hate it so much that is very rude
it's short now you can't just say you
hate it wow only three women can pull
off short hair like that audrey hepburn
halle berry and ellen degeneres guys are
not gonna go for this i'm telling you
they're not gonna deal with it all right
well it's a good thing you're not my
boyfriend yeah it is a good thing i like
it
it might grow on me we both have the
same haircut now
i told christina i
i want to slow things down so
i think that's
they got something
there was just
hello schmutz
you're at the golden globes okay you
just tripped
and fell on the red carpet no yes the
whole world is watching your face down
your dress is over your head toby
maguire is laughing at you the whole
world is watching what are you gonna do
you're gonna sit there and cry you're
gonna push yourself up
and show them what best actress in a
mini-series or motion picture made for
television nominee mindy lahiri is made
of what are you gonna do
nice that was great did i win no you
lost to stalker channing
why are you naked why are you in the
girl's game it's co-ed
here here fine take my towel that is so
much worse
don't drop it on the floor your genitals
what was on that pick it up it's my
favorite towel
mindy i think we have a little problem
uh
huh outside sorry sorry i'm sorry why
did you wear a watch to a steamroller
it's a 35
watch i'm not gonna leave it in the
locker room oh god just turn just turn
oh my god oh my god
don't use me for leverage nothing this
is nothing
oh
[Music]
what the hell was that close the door
look at her close the door that was you
on the inside what do you want me to do
get out get out do you want me out of
the the office or the building in
general cause i you just got to be clear
with me right now get out of here and
close the door
behind you okay i'm going i'm not
looking i'm a gentleman i'm going
great thank you if i catch the bird you
want me to bring it back
i'm going to kill you okay i i get it
you're
self-conscious i understand you but you
have no reason to be all i was gonna say
is don't suck in your stomach so much
it makes you makes you look nervous and
frankly a little constipated
and get a boob job no that's not what i
was gonna say
and get rid of the cellulite on your
legs no and have blue eyes
i don't want that oh you're a woman and
that's good look like a woman
sometimes the best gifts don't cost
anything
i guess if you're like a poor mouse and
a christmas special
okay here we go it's been a long time
when you first started working here you
used to play this nonstop it was the
first thing about you that ever really
annoyed me
[Music]
or
oh
[Music]
anyway i can get you a gift card or
write a personal check
don't worry about just just just don't
tell morgan or jeremy about it okay
what are you talking about i loved it
you liked it
mindy give me that boob wine hey i
really
appreciate this thank you so much a nice
payment
one tonic water
thanks i will be right back
oh brother
hey hey danny all these waters look the
same i i just don't
[Music]
get out bravest if i've been naked i
need to explain something to you
what then i slap some grad student from
europe he's gonna go back to his country
and say in america hot girls can just do
whatever they want that's a bad message
danny what were you even trying to do
i thought i was being romantic okay
you'd get to the top of the empire state
building and see it was me and
everything would be okay
that is the stupidest thing i have ever
heard you're a liar
you slash andy maybe break up with
charlie okay and then he stood me up
at my favorite place in the entire world
i didn't want to tell you
because i knew i knew this would happen
i knew would push you away
i love you mindy i love you
i want to be with you look at me i want
to be with you i believe you yes you do
i don't believe why
because you love me until you don't okay
i'm not gonna do that again i want
something real danny
this is real it's real
i can prove it to you tonight eight
o'clock meet me on the top of the empire
state building i don't care if you say
no i will wait all night for you please
please please just give me another
chance
i can't go why because i have plans
to do what to not be the stupidest
person in the world
mindy
midday
[Music]
mindy
i'm sorry mindy
who's gonna tell you when
[Music]
it's too late
who's gonna tell you things
[Music]
my heart is racing so is mine i thought
i lost you shut up shut up what did you
if you come to this stupid place
because you love it i love you
me i want to go all in really
in public all these people all right no
no like all in like gambling
okay i'm okay okay
i like that yeah let's get something to
eat
our first date you're paying yeah i
gotta get used to it since i'm gonna be
the breadwinner and you're gonna be the
stay-at-home mom
i'm not quitting my job and if we have
kids we're gonna get like a million
nannies to take care of them all ugly
you perv
one kid one child one maximum and it's
gonna be a boy what we're having nine
girls
no we are not having nine girls yes we
are named after all the muses
[Music]
calliope
tonight